what makes Magnus so good what are the
various aspects of his game that make
him so good I think for Magnus he he
just you know that in the end game in
the end games if you get there he's just
he's not gonna blunder that's the first
thing so you know if you reach an end
game he's not going to make a mistake he
obviously plays great openings and
there's just really no defined weakness
that he has there's no weakness that I
can think of very specifically
um many there are many times where
players actually out prepare him in the
opening phase but as soon as they're on
their own and they have to think very
often times they'll make mistakes
um so there's just no weakness for
Magnus really no weakness well unlike
say Casper like kasparab on the other
hand there there are very clear
weaknesses
um in his game like kramnik exploit them
first of all very I don't want to say
like
ego is the right word but like very
stubborn believing that his openings
were infallible that he could just win
he could just prove an advantage and win
the game out of the opening like against
kramnik when he ultimately lost also
generally not a great defender either
very strong tactically but if he was in
positions that were defensive he would
make mistakes and lose in end games like
he did in one of those games in the
world championship against cram next so
there were very clear defined weaknesses
in Sparrow's game
um whereas like magnets are just they're
no clearly defined weaknesses maybe
maybe he doesn't like being attacked
maybe that's the one thing he likes King
safety and he doesn't like being
attacked but that's not something that
you can easily do whereas say uh if
someone's very tactical and they're not
a strong positionally that is something
you can def that will happen quite
frequently in games you can steer games
a certain way doesn't mean you'll always
get there but that is something tangible
whereas King safety that's not something
tangible at all it's very very hard to
attack someone uh based on unless they
play certain style of openings